[Music]
[Applause]
I heard you overheard mouth this morning
so my thesis is titled when all you have
is a bad hammer and it is about online
volunteer community moderation and I
wonder was something like that I have
been one test phone I animal and have
been for the last seven years and so my
person this topic was really kind of
sparked around when I came into this
program and I saw all sort of this
uptick of concerns around online
harassment and anti harassment what we
should do it
remember we using a lot of the solutions
of reading through a lot of what people
wanted to me to combat this and I
thought no this is wrong let me tell you
why but we're going to do that and
either you know take a step back didn't
say well what is moderation and kind of
following on from that who's motivated
for command would walk and so moderation
is something I like to call it invisible
labor right it is work that is not
supposed to be seen when we think about
online moderation if we think about it
at all it's something that we believe
should be hidden away
right but the traces of it every family
should be covered up as smoothly and
quickly and neatly as possible so all of
the CEO ideally all the scars telling
you about moderation
happened like will comment impedance in
I don't know a news article comments
section but the problem with that is
that it also means that the people
are also think about the last time you
might have read about online moderation
possibly in relation to the revelations
about Facebook data leaves right it's
rare that we think about moderators as
human people we like to think about them
as systems you think about them as all
gorillas so through all this right where
are the people on what are they do it
and so once again just a little to
clarify it I propose that there are two
kind of main types of moderation that we
see on the internet and there's a
commercial content moderation right
where this moderation work is being
carried out by contracted workers often
outsource to places like senator centers
Philippines we do sort of large-scale
content removal work with great little
contracts and very little connection to
the communities or mail moderating and
the other type which I want to pay much
more attention to in my thesis is
community management where the men over
the moderators have a much closer
connection to the communities of their
moderating and often are drawn from
those same communities that they will
then govern and regulate so going one
step more precisely you know one step
more specific and talk about volunteer
community motivation right because
sometimes just work exists sort of as
paid labor as a paid community
management position but I want to look
at the people who volunteer and don't
expect any compensation for the work
that they perform and even in the cases
where they do that compensation it is so
vanishingly rare it might as well not
exist so there are once again they're
very close to the communities that they
were maybe they didn't mean close
I'm all right generally speaking the
motivations for them choosing to
volunteer might be shaped by existing
values without saying what bar is
trivial what motivation is good at who
should it be performed before but
crucially they don't the values have
been developed as a consequence of doing
this work don't have to then respect
them right so this is my long-winded way
of saying just because they're not
compensated and because they're
performing work for a company it is too
simple to portray the relationship
purely as one of someone's being
exploited by someone else who has a home
power right but it's it's still in
balance it's not that simple it's not
quite that long sighted the work that
they do is shaped by the affordances of
the platform or platforms that there are
so for example you know depending on how
the problem is so depending on how it's
designed depending on for example how
you become a moderator of what kind of
permissions of moderator has the kind of
work that they can do will be different
and they are constantly in a complex web
of relationships with different kind of
interest holders whether that be the
operators fellow moderators that or the
community themselves of their romantic
government and all of these
relationships have different interests
acumen different weights and different
kinds of tensions and frictions so just
keeping all that in mind my case study
is on large-scale
esports chat moderation on twitch.tv so
it's which is a popular live streaming
site I'll show you some screenshots as
we get further into this so the
moderators that I interviewed
he says you were drawn from a pool of
regular a semi-regular eSports event
moderators I conducted several in-depth
interviews with them and also did a
stint as a junior moderator for IEM
katowice which was this five game video
game tournament so my interviewees had
between one and five years of moderation
experience on switch specifically some
of them had more from previous
communities and different platforms they
moderated for a variety of games and a
variety of eSports scenes and for a
variety of organizations with different
goals so some of these for example are
you know done for charity and some of
these are more so quote unquote
traditional eSports organizations that
like and say such thing exists and the
audience sizes that they were used to
kind of have it range could range from
you know a thousand concurrent years
term and the largest and most extreme
case over 1 million it becomes about
2017 eb penetrator go so you know these
are a huge huge crowd that we're talking
about and what we were talking about
this huge huge crowds this is what the
chat looks like what was brought in for
a couple of seconds I highly advise not
trying to read it don't make my mistakes
so how do you want to rate this well I
would propose that we think of
moderation with something I call the
reactive model
here's hand diagram it's very simple it
basically goes okay so users do think
only into that where they produce
content they they
behaviors and then a moderator will see
nothing and the moderation is that for
right the moderator either does
something about it or they do nothing
about it and this is a kind of general
summation of what I think we generally
think of moderation ads right when we
think of people like a comment removing
comments reporting people thanking
people there are just variations on the
state right a moderator has I think
learned something about or they're going
to do nothing about it and it's
positions moderators that's inherently
reacting to things that users do and
that the reaction usually means removal
although some mentio you'll see for
example pinning comments are promoting
the most of the strategy operations of
us a lot rarer and it's also focused on
the event over google it basically
understands moderation as a series of
kind of points right like a series of
little events of removal that kind of
happened on mass and that's what
moderation is well I propose that we
really need to expand into the parlance
I'm not saying that moderators don't
react to things that users do but
there's a lot more to it than this
simple before so I throw something I'm
I'm calling the proactive model right so
where the reactive model says moderators
are apparently reactive the private
mobile says moderator and actions aren't
bound to using content right they don't
it's not just about reactive to user
contact well the other thing is that
moderators do can be about a whole range
of things
moderation work doesn't just mean
removal right it sometimes there's
nothing to do with the regulation of
what you see like content lies on those
platforms and instead of focusing on
individual acts of moderation I found us
to be attentive so the fact that
moderators carry knowledge of previous
events for and anticipate future user
reactions and actions to what they do as
moderators and on top of that water
heaters are constantly community
before different groups and as they
communicate they create social groups
they create social norms and they create
social patterns so let's jump right into
twitch right so this is what your
typical twitch viewer might see exactly
my account
don't want you seeing my evening so this
is it's so dominate but it's big video
feed and there's this little chat on my
life your life and that cat is what we
want to talk about right so if this were
newbie this child you get it as fast as
what I've showed you previously and so
you know one of the things that you just
ask my interviewees hey can you share
some screenshots of what you see while
you've already said oh yeah oh this is
what I'm looking at okay this is
different for one let's not go to this
big there's like you're watching for
chats at once okay okay and say oh I
don't know I have three monitors this is
what's on the line it's a disorder
chatroom and this is and this is what's
on the break I don't even see an
attached but there's like a ball so like
automated moderator script dashboards in
there there are tools looking at
actually multiple that's words there
would be Twitter there looking at other
twitch channels so they're profiting a
lot more than they're experiencing
twitch they're experiencing this planet
in a much different way than you are
refusing and so I asked that okay during
then about what do you do and this is
crucial because if I moderators do
remove a lot of things right as
publicist I go where my interest
what they do not and I have to figure
something I just made up righteousness
of reacting to user content so if
anything you would expect them to follow
that like work the most closely and I
saw I asked
walk me through hypothetically how you
would handle a bit of lag and said okay
so first we spawn it and this is looking
like a generalized answer based off
their their responses then we would put
this message into a blacklist right so
part of the way that they handle like
sheer volume of content is that they use
a lot of automated strips the majority
of which are actually third party
created like made by hots for mods
rather than relying solely on what has
been built into the platform right so
they put the red flag message or spam
comment into these blacklist for 600
seconds for 10 minutes while they
continue monitoring either personally or
sort of a delegated stroke to watch and
make sure that nobody's time again
around this new filter life because as I
said the chat can tell when you've bad
something and there we were trying to
get around it and so if necessary right
if after that 600 seconds times out and
it's no longer bad and it comes back and
it starts disrupting again don't put it
into a regular expression filter which
think of it as a more powerful longer
term solution to stopping that message
for being repeated and during this
process if necessary a moderator may try
to distract chat by basically giving
them a scene of something to take and
kind of span and mean and joke about
that isn't going to be offensive that is
going to distract them away from the
fact that somebody's just been written
and they keep the trap going
everyone entertain and after the event
so this is happening constantly as these
events which for example so I was
moderating during a final event that was
five hours long and so this is happening
constantly through those five hours and
after the event we had monitors might
evaluate these new filters will consider
okay which one of these should maybe go
longer term which one of these
constitutes for example a upgrade to
existing tools we have or maybe they'll
say okay Louie this particular message
might not show up in the future we're
going to get rid of it just in case that
it kind of turns up a false positive in
the future so even just the act of
removal that's far more complicated than
the mirroring action right we can see
that they are thinking already of
anticipating responses and also followed
by the president right thinking about
what has worked before what strategies
for dealing with traffic worked before
and it leaves you mad a little bit
before and after the event there's
already working right before the event
had moderators have to come first find
their team like they have to recruit
people and they have to program these
automated tools with the appropriate
filters with the appropriate commands to
give users information and so on so
forth and this is not really an
anticipation to what users are doing it
all right they're doing it because for
example even organizer will say hey we
want you to advertise this related then
we're going to
or maybe they'll decide okay wanna
recruit this many people because as a
matter of our own policy with this
policy the motivators develop this is
the optimal number we've determined
before events of both sides but the
thing is even as they're doing this type
of work even as they're making these
judgement calls all of that rests on the
development and kind of the ability to
navigate the tricky waters of an even
more complicated social relationship
right and this is something where I
think the social work of the moderators
really comes into play and that is their
relationship to twitch chat because
moderation requires this kind of
relationship of trust it's not really
positive or negative and it can be quite
combative but it needs to be better for
their work to function you know a
moderator I interview described twitch
chat as a thb saying what I've learned
over the years is that chat behaves the
bit like a feast if you can't you're in
too small then we've got really angry
and try to be as offensive and hateful
as possible but if you set the past
quite loosely then they shut it down
and another person said when you watch
chat for so long you pretty much know
what's gonna happen when it happens it's
like being the twitch chat whisperer you
just know everything and underneath I've
put up some examples of spam so one
really common thing you'll see at these
events is that people because it's going
so fast people are repeating little
messages mimetic
attention you know that might be in
jokes they might just Brian we have
funny use of
emotes but there are a lot actually that
are directly related to moderators and
so making fun instead of kind of poking
at the moderators attention span and
ability to control chat so the one that
I picked up for you are slow and steady
wins the race
at this pace me or candy spam no hado
back have the moths banned us all with
judicious musical thinking emerging and
also this last one is interesting
because it represents you know someone
trying to trick other people into
thinking that our moderator it's hella
done the visited back with the channel
would you really only works if the
people who both haven't actually seen
them all bad people from the channel
able it is a fascinating relationship
and I think what it there should really
clearly that this is a this is a
relationship that isn't static right
it's extremely dynamic it kind of flows
not even over the course of two except
it's over the course of a single event
you know alibi hour minute by minute
it's going to change and this is
something that modern readers keep on
top of if they want to be able to work
because of as I said you know they know
that some of the users are trying to
test the batteries to see if they can't
get around these filters so part of
moderating means that you have to get
cat to be on your side broadly speaking
you have to make sure of that there
aren't too many people trying to test
your authority and set those boundaries
the way that they do it is by trying to
maintain this kind of working
relationship with chat so let's step
back even further okay beyond a single
event how did we even become you know
what's the life cycle because they're
coming from somewhere and presumably
they're gonna go somewhere else and so
you know I asked them my about things
like how did you become a moderator how
did you learn to be a moderator and what
happens when people leave so what I
learned was that oftentimes these
moderators are promoted for being
basically regular community members
people who visit a
community and get noticed for being
safer to be really helpful for their
kind of their attitude towards other
people in charge was previously
moderators and some of them might
volunteer or be asked to join a
motivation team but the other thing that
they all had in common just every single
time was that they had a lot of free
time which make sense when you think
about it but in micro 3 conditions I
think for miscomi where a student
unemployed and or injured because when
you ever make you have a lot of time to
happen when these words relax
how are you treating how do you learn
and what I found was that there's very
little in the way of a formal training
process a lot of this informal and a lot
of it follows a sort of mentorship model
so new moderators are brought into these
moderator only social spaces often chat
really showed bravery flee a snippet of
where moderators are not only teaching
one another how to moderate right and
you know not only talk about like oh you
should set your box to this sensitivity
you should try it in this book you
should try this new tool but they are
also talking about things like hey
should we ban people in this
circumstance should we or on the side of
being heart should we be more lenient
they'll be talking about things like
what's Twitter's new community guideline
policy and what does that mean for us
because more on the ground China
forcibly has this new organization put
up a new rule how does that mean we have
to now respond and so not only are these
spaces places where people are learning
it's also places where people are
developing and ethics of moderation
they're developing a value system from
automation their development their
development what I would call it
the murmuration right and sort of as
they spend time and start contributing
to these discussions they kind of slowly
from a constitutive culture of
moderating on Twitter and as they learn
they also progress through what I
hesitate call practice because it's
deeply informal and no one actually uses
these terms or something like from being
a junior moderator to see a mother to
ahead moderator and that seems to
roughly correspond from sort of self
reporting to participants own sense of
confidence on taking moderator actually
without getting a second opinion or
review but also to the kinds of
responsibilities that they take on
especially for head moderators who kind
of perform a much more managerial role
rather than actually doing any critical
hands-on or agent way so instead of
watching cat they might be watching the
moderated moderated chat there are there
to arbitrate disputes they are there to
go through policy questions that are
there to talk and kind of right as I
said mentor newer moderators and so in
some instances for example while I was
moderating our moderator wasn't once
you've had a lot I was popping in and
out of the chattering and making sure we
were on top of things that we when being
overwhelmed but he did not have to be
present and so it cannot come to the end
of the life cycle that sort of a
difficult question of well why do people
leave and so some of them said well what
happens when you don't have that free
time anymore when you're an either a
student normal employed and you're fully
healthy what's more you don't have time
and you know some are you talking about
like spending upwards of 10 hours every
day over Omega to commit to these events
and one extreme case I had a moderator
told me that because they live in
to the event they would change on their
sleep schedule so they could more
closely mimic the timezone of where the
event was happening so they could be a
week when the events were happening so
they could work and added to the fact
that they're not being compensated
whether this is in terms of money or all
points of compensation and it's
difficult there's no amount of support
and so a lot of them kind of burn out or
they have great commitments elsewhere
and they can no longer perform this work
and most interesting ly some of the
people I talked to did understand
quality of moderation as one possible
path to getting in a professional career
a professional position in eSports but
equally interestingly very few of these
positions make full use of the expertise
that they develop as volunteer moderator
right so for example all positions that
they mentioned as as though that were
often staffed by ex moderators were
production and social media management
and all these are kind of tendentially
really you can understand it because
they're all they all consider themselves
part of that scene right part of
Kennedy's works community first neither
of those really take full advantage of
that kind of deep social and even
technical knowledge that these volunteer
moderators are developing on the job
this one took a heart of the matter to
the positive most abstractly right what
makes a good moderator of good I talked
about the operation process where they
sit there but what does that look like
from what does that mean
and what do they think of all this so
you know I asked how did you lunch
Margaret a lot of who couldn't tell me
because they couldn't remember I don't
think that point to the fact that
they're not learning or they're not
being taught I think it just points to
the fact that it's subtle and slow and
something that happens over time in a
ways that we may not know it as
consciously uncle asked about it right
so I asked our one person gave an
anecdote of when they started off saying
when I first got modded I don't think
that obviously people who would drop the
n-bomb love was all I did for a little
while then I started looking at things
like how the timeout
and three or four seconds later I would
see the senior long time that out I did
that for a couple of weeks and then I
was like about it everything I wanted to
do and we've got a good hacker community
so you notice that there is a conscious
modeling of that Maroons behavior are
normal and not just in terms of judgment
calls but in terms of kind of like a
good handle for the community like the
relationship to the community doesn't
moderated because when they're making
technical the supposed to be like I'm
gonna turn that out for 10 minutes I'm
gonna turn that out for 5 minutes I'm
gonna buy this person permanently
they're not following a strict code of
guidelines because there's no time to
the china progressing so fast that
there's not like a reference document
the program saying I have somebody drop
the n-bomb this many times you ban them
out for this many seconds okay it is up
to the individual moderator and getting
that judgment learning what kind of
action is appropriate to take for what
kind of it if there is a really
important part of learning how to be a
moderator and crucially one that people
did not always fully articulate the
second thing is that these moderators
are forming organized communities right
they're gathering in these combination
training rounds discussion spaces and
support networks and often you know I
would
see mother is saying hey I found this
for three referral from another group I
found this because and all the moderator
told me this group existed right
so as I'm normal as these systems of
localization maybe they're definitely
less powerful and I've led to this
writing seen as flying community of
moderators on Twitch and the things that
they talk about don't just revolve
around well don't just go around doing
the moderation sometimes it brings up
the issue of the costs of motivation
every moderator race book - and every
moderator I know has been threatened at
some point in the career for being a
moderator and in fact most of my
participants told me that they received
threats for the laughs because it was so
normal to them and that forms the basis
of a lot of their doing but they would
joke about it for example every single
person on the market receiving a death
threat from one of the extremely
persistent users which when I say it out
loud isn't really funny anymore but the
problem is that with the squirt being
invisible with the word is being
invisible there's not a lot of places
they can turn to one of the moderators
with Coty said that the problem is I
can't really talk about this because
they think it's just people talking on
the Internet that doesn't matter and so
this means that these social spaces form
an incredibly important support
children's support network for
moderators and they try to kind of
handle the emotional and mental costs of
moderation and also start building out
the tools and the networks that they
need to continue doing this work and so
wrap it up I have a few points that I
would like to emphasize
you know simply it is to say nourishment
work and it deserves to be treated as
such it's something that requires
forethought that's something that
requires planning and a great deal of
this work the social and communicative
not merely technical right so when we
think about moderation of it we're you
know kind of just keep in mind who are
the people behind the square the people
before me those who are the people
coming up with those judgment calls and
ultimately what are the kinds of values
what are the kind of overarching diving
philosophies that those actions are
communicated all these supports side we
desperately need better support for
volunteer moderators but they probably
should get compensated which is a
reality that what a lot of my
interviewee says like yes someone should
be but I recognize that in the current
state of things I probably won't so my
question was why not when we start
thinking of moderation as work rather
than something you pull in for a crisis
to fix maybe this is something we can
learn some sort of plan in as a part of
the cost of running these offenses a
part of setting up the community on
client way we need to think about the
labor conditions in on top of that you
know composition is not the only way we
should be thinking about we need it okay
who can afford to spend 10 hours of the
time every single day you know Friday
through to Sunday doing these jobs for
no compensation what's the kind of
hardware that they need one of the kinds
of internet connections of them you know
I've had a lot already said my laptop
diet is to a chef is going too fast
don't think my computer right so what
are the kind of material conditions
necessary for this work to happen we
need to think about communication
between moderators and organizations lot
higher than I spoke at length about
they're moderators but another thing
that shocked me was a relatively
speaking there's not a lot of clear
communication between all two moderators
and the people who are hiring them for
free I had someone are going to say that
you know I used to advocate for myself
to be like hey I see you're running an
event would you like me to work for you
for free to help you clean up your
catacomb they said well after a while I
stopped because I you think that could
have been taken as an insult but it's a
shame but would be Linda but somebody
has to be like I want to work with
before you for no money please don't
take this the wrong way and lastly we
really need better mental health support
you know like I said a cornerstone of
moderation humor is the facts
embarrassing but it's got a lot of ways
that moderators trying to cope with the
stresses of the job in addition to the
ongoing global Evelyn fragments of just
harassment and abuse is through humor
and through these coding methods but at
the same time that there are structural
reasons why this is the case there are
structural reasons why burnout is such a
persistent Spectre over the community
and he's a think that we definitely need
to adjust going forward moderation has
existed and it has always existed in
online spaces and the difference has
always been and how visible they are we
need to make the work visible but we
also need to make the workers physical
and when we limit our understanding of
moderation we [ __ ] our ability to
recognize their work and [ __ ] our
ability to create better moderation
tools and to properly appreciate sort of
the scope and they unique challenges of
this work for moderators and so what I
wrote my title when I wrote it first I
love the sentence when only half of a
bad hour because that's what we think of
moderator
doing or having friends I've got this
big harmony swinging around and they ban
users and they smash posts but I'd like
to hear more about why people choose to
the moderators beyond what they they
have that time to do it but and we made
a reference to a sort of other
community's commitment to do sports but
literal what are all the through range
of factors that would draw you to do
this ruling challenging so the mask was
about motivates moderators to do this
work when I asked my response during the
frame it in terms of say community
engagement and altruism so kind of in
human language I am out here I really
like the space I wanted to help or I
wanted to contribute or I saw that there
was a way for Mina use my expertise for
example in the case of people who work
at dozen programming I understood
and I wanted to get back I did have one
interviewee
who faced it in terms like you know I
want to make sure the communities that
work for abide by the in terms of
service so that they are protected in
case McLaughlin decides to take action
against them
what is this a very important an
arranged date and I will have happy
there might be some where I have more
space but yeah like the the sort of
student motivation Muslims had was this
this feeling of wanting to give back
know whether or not this was that
effective the fact that they knew they
were talking to me and also like this
isn't don't think that you're supposed
to express this part of me you know good
mother and that's on yourself list
because some of them also did say that
yeah there are bad messages there
moderators who do this because they're
selfish they want the power and so one
thing he was like yeah I was like that
when I first started out well that's how
did you get here I just have to work I
have to you know learn to and I cook
both the community as a moderator rather
than implicitly where they just as a
user
thanks to this is really fascinating
I've got my sessions where y'all just 81
today you so one of the ways that some
of the platforms justify the move to a
commercial model talk about is the
question of scale right can't possibly
do this and you described a pretty big
range of scale so could be a thousand
people could be a million so what did
you notice how the moderators deal with
that kind of extreme fluctuation of
scale you know from a thousand to a
million so one of the most striking
things I'll say about that actors would
have million viewers had as they said oh
there were three or four of us and it
was fine it was actually less rather
than the like 400,000 troops viewer or
chats we get now I think a lot of it
goes back to that ability to understand
the social tournament social dynamics on
twitch chat' they're doing this work
part of it also is the wider
availability of automated tools so what
supplements which will moderate our
registers or machine learning power chat
precision tool they said you know in the
beginning wasn't that great but now it's
good but crucially it's also not the
only totally rely on a second space like
four weeks ago so I a surprise it's sort
of partly that I know it's ever after a
certain point but doesn't really matter
how big it is if you understand that
you've what you're looking for is a
pattern and so the problem is not
necessarily like how do we cope with the
volume of information is can we so
accurately spot
certainly destroy
patterns of computer and that's what
they're freaking out and so I would say
still is my concern but it taught me for
to use number one which has the
reputation for being a toxic place I've
been a number of scandals in the eSports
Idina related to either eSports growth
or the chance of being extremely
extremely racist and women's in a video
game tournament they're also pretty
sexist sometimes and thus a thing of
moderators address however weekly so
what an invention is that one of them
said while we're setting up I'm
paraphrasing we asked for lists of who's
going to be on screen like who are the
caster to the app because if any of them
are a minority we're gonna prepare fill
up we're gonna put in extra filters we
have protocols in place for anticipating
sexism for anticipating traps for a
reason with etcetera that they don't
like to roll out again for fear of false
positives sort of on game day basis but
it is something that preparing for when
it comes in the race and gender of the
moderators I generally don't know as I
was conducting this research I need a
decision that I would try to embassy
as anonymous as possible so I didn't ask
for age I didn't ask for names outside
of they were contacted me with I didn't
ask for although identifying information
I will tell you my sense of the space
burger just have been in there's our
mail while in a European so the American
race but I've had a cultural gap isn't
people have to navigate because they
have to be sensitive to American
expressions of racism in American
stereotypes one of them said there's
actually a want expand look out for and
it's spam that's trying to trick people
into being racist when they're don't
realize that they're being racist
because they're not familiar with the
stereotypes all of those words or I
obviously don't know how to approach it
just like that
so thanks presentation and can't wait to
read it
your frame your argument by asking that
will be made visible and if the workers
need a kiss Louis way to sort of in the
ordinary situation and that makes a lot
of sensitive but then you want under
your discussion to talk about basically
implicit knowledge a self-selecting
community that has implicit knowledge
that's kind of intuitive from what your
seniors are doing and and that's really
that's powerful interesting but I wonder
why that implicit knowledge is nothing
they explicit as a way it helped us be
defined as body work within
institutional cultures that like this
does have to sort of mentioned the
culture that recognizes jobs and Jenna
sort of so let's accept to ameliorate
this we've made visible invisible
seemed like summarize your question for
the sake of the livestream so what if
you first say that you're asking me a
question about how could you do what are
the ways of making that visible or
invisible in a way that would be
recognizable let's say finding a new
person how do you make the implicit
knowledge and they're picking up some
like mentorship models in Washington
being in the space visible so I merely
thought might happen I'm looking for
jobs and I think a part of it is that
the I will say that the a version of
this volunteer labor isn't valued very
highly but you see stuff like community
manager decisions often entry-level jobs
and there isn't a pathway up right so
even before you can talk about kind of
like making that job into a saving of
more institutionalized form of knowledge
which has a lot of benefits I was like
there is an issue of kind of culture on
that level as well
but listen got to kind of codifying the
invisible penguins that some groups do
actually now circulate documents
guidelines for moderation but the thing
is that they're still drive often 22
precedent and memory and sorry
historical knowledge of events as a
predictor or justification for why these
guy back should be the way that they are
I have a target even I'm not really
getting to your question
so just implicitly question maybe is
that you talk about a self-selecting
community that's running a lot of time
and energy is this something that you
and we're implicit knowledge is
precisely the binary community as soon
as you make it explicit you're over here
to the world and it's not exactly many I
think it's less the implicit knowledge
that's binding much too much is a shared
set of attitudes and values towards the
work that they do just because as I said
child is actually a very aware of the
fact that every mother in it so even if
it's not spell I put them what they're
doing and what these patterns are there
is a consciousness on sort of as both
the user and as a moderator of what are
the guidelines broad strokes maybe not
kind of what's going on with how this is
regulated and what's acceptable behavior
so yeah and I think that's the thing
it's always going to be hard to make
explicit the kind of shared values
towards this work especially with her
changing like they're all exchanging so
[Music]
should be offered like two moderators
but how would that kind of compensation
look in like how would that change the
nature of moderation by introducing the
kind of like
so first day there needs to be a lot
about how would that compensation figure
into moderation and how does that change
the nature of my community I generally
do not know but like the practically hub
of it are complicated intraday not least
because a lot of these organizations are
for example American Quarter German or
European and the moderators really learn
and in fact they select for moderators
who are suing have done walk twenty four
seven times of coverage so just our
legal level it it's tricky I do know
that there are some organizations who
provide monetary compensation for
example ERP tickets or free access to
events invitations to ask parties and as
I've said you know when one considers
what's all part of the Bandon for each
what seen that it can be quite valuable
it's not like you know let me make that
clear it's not the same thing but it is
showing that kind of recognition that it
is labor or I'm showing an appreciation
for the fact about neighbors uniformed I
was another should be the way but a lot
of them actually what about me she get
paid were very aware of some of the
financial realities stream and how much
money she communities
and consequently saying they couldn't
afford me if they were paying me a fair
wage for that amount of hours at the
pool they couldn't afford any of us and
wish me to people and the quality of
work would go down the drain and that's
why we do I don't want to comment
I
but hardwired innovation have always
happened it is that you know it doesn't
always take a form you sometimes it is
so somebody who knows though respected
and has a kind of social Oh
drops comments saying hey we all say
that early but not even or or just
participate during and so people know
that they're present and I would fall
but I would have enough moderation right
so even if the Papa doesn't mess
- affordances to allow this kind of
robust monitoring work I would be highly
surprised nobody
[Applause]